two veteran members of the House
representatives at the table and with
the morning newspapers we're going to
begin today with representative nancy
Johnson of Connecticut good morning good
morning nice to be with you what are you
reading today that first caught your
attention you want to talk about well
what first costs might caught my
attention was a small article about a
hearing that I'm going to chair this
morning on the IRS's responsibility to
implement electronic filing for all
small businesses actually a lot of
people are already filing electronically
and the IRS has smoothly implemented the
first parts of the program so hundreds
of thousands of taxpayers are already
filing electronically successfully but
the way they have managed this final
part of the program to get small
businesses to file electronically has
really been absolutely a disaster their
letter to the small businesses was not
clear they didn't make the choice is
clear they blamed NAFTA I mean it's just
been a disaster and it's unfortunately
another example of the IRS is failure to
really be customer front sensitive you
know the taxpayer is the one that really
needs to understand what their
obligation is and how to go about
fulfilling it and the IRS has done a lot
actually to improve how it does its
business but it continues to absolutely
fail to address the needs of the
ordinary public of the consuming public
and those who want to responsibly care
it responsibly carry out their taxpaying
responsibilities and we're going to go
into that why why does this keep
happening and how can we correct it will
there be and given the current tenor on
Capitol Hill fundamental change of the
IRS I believe there will be I think
there will be on two scores first of all
we have a commission on restructuring
the IRS bipartisan it's been functioning
very well doing very in-depth work and I
think they're going to report out a
dramatic proposal for restructuring to
gain the in the IRS the independence it
needs and the authority that it means
under Treasury it's been terribly
managed and it really truly its needs
ignored in addition I think the Congress
has a responsibility to radically
simplify the tax codes you really get
into this and we have asked the IRS to
end
clemente tax law that no one understands
including tax experts you can't succeed
in doing that so complexity is a real
cause of the IRS's failure to operate in
a way Americans can be proud of so
Congress needs to simplify the tax law
but we need to restructure the agency
also at the table congressman Bernie
Sanders of Vermont mr. Sanders and many
of the papers noted that this April
fifteenth as almost every year we see
all kinds of discussion about the IRS
and tax policy will do you believe there
will be changed I believe there should
be changed and I agree with a lot of
Nancy's concerns about the complexity of
the tax code and also about the
inefficiencies of the IRS one of the
concerns that we have in the England
Nancy by the way is the Vermont Maine
and New Hampshire been merged with
Massachusetts doing away with our
central offices and what we're finding
in Vermont is a lot of people are
finding it more difficult to get the
information that they need they're
calling up a 1-800 number and busted and
then phone keeps ringing and they put on
hold so we're not very impressed by that
reorganization it seems to simply make
the IRS a little bit consumer less
friendly and it's causing a lot of
concern of Vermont throughout New
England Nancy also raises another
concern and we all know that sometimes
the IRS is blamed unfairly they do not
make the tax law they have to implement
that the Congress makes the law and i
agree with nancy about the need for
simplification but on the other hand we
should not kid ourselves the concern
that I have about tax law is that from
1977 to nineteen ninety nine nine to
nineteen seventy-seven to nineteen
ninety Congress passed seven major
pieces of tax law the result of that is
the taxes went down for the very
wealthiest people in America and the
largest corporations it went up for
ninety percent of the people to working
people in the middle class so why we
want to move toward tax simplicity we
also in my view what a move toward a
progressive tax system which ask the
wealthiest people in large groups
corporations to start paying their fair
share of taxes rather than the middle
class well I certainly don't disagree
with the fact that the wealthier people
ought to pay more and the fact is that
when we reduce the rates they are now
paying more and they pay more now under
the lower tax rates than they did under
the higher tax rates as a percentage of
total take yeah but you're excluding the
Social Security tax what has happened is
yeah and what is happening Mary
well I know but what happened during the
1980s under both Republicans and
Democrats is there was a massive shift
of the tax burden from upper income
people to the middle class primarily
through the payroll tax which went way
up so right now as you know everybody
pays seven and a half percent your
employee of a seven-and-a-half presenta
less as many people in vermont that you
are self-employed you pay fifteen
percent of payroll tax before you pay
your first nickel in income tax that
more people pay more in payroll tax when
they pay an income tax i think there was
a massive shift from upper income people
and from large corporations corporations
for their taxes go down as you know in
the 1950s corporations paid off a thirty
percent of the taxes that came into the
federal come today they're paying less
than 10 / certainly is no question but
that the payroll tax is regressive in
the sense that it's the same percentage
of wage for everyone but the increase in
the payroll tax was part of Congress
trying to save the Social Security
system and one of the things we need to
do this year in tax reform is to give
taxpayers a lot more help in other
savings mechanisms because if you save
young you really can retire with great
security and we need to help people use
their money to create retirement
security much more effectively than the
Social Security system does damson okay
because I know we'll get some calls on
it I let me first of all tell people
that you are welcome to call and I'll
put the c-span phone numbers on the
bottom of screen and get to your calls
your faxes in your emails in just a
couple of minutes Mr Sanders you have
had a chance to have to tell us about a
story you're following what's fun caught
your eye it seems the same story keeps
appearing in all the papers in the
different forms at page 1 of the New
York Times big bond firms are still
giving to politicians Wall Street a
Bayes rule but exploits loophole same
story in a dozen different papers and
that is that we continue to see a
national disgrace in terms of how the
political parties and politicians raise
money for their campaigns clearly there
is something wrong when corporate
America and big money interests are able
to contribute hundreds of thousands of
dollars the political parties
significant amounts of money to
candidates and the result of that I
think is you end up having a Congress
which by and large ends up working for
the wealthy and big money rather than
for the needs of the middle class and
working families my own view is that the
disgrace and the scandals involved in
campaign fight of fundraising one of the
reasons that fewer and fewer people are
voting you know when mr. gingrich in his
friends took power in 94 all of thirty
eight percent of the people voted in
this last presidential election we had
forty-nine percent of the people thought
is I think unless we get a handle on
campaign finance reform and we say that
big money cannot continue to buy
elections that we move toward a system
with public funding and which provides
incentives to candidates go out get
small contributions that unless we do
that people become more and more
discouraged and alienated from the
political process comment honest well
certainly I think we need to do campaign
finance reform and I'm a strong advocate
of campaign finance reform but frankly
Bernie I don't know a member of Congress
now maybe I'm just not not don't know
the right people but I don't know a
member of Congress who determines their
votes on the basis of contributors I
determine my votes on the needs of the
people I represent and honestly most
members are intensely concerned with the
lives of the people they represent their
economic opportunities their job
opportunities the social service network
that supports people in need the quality
of public education access to health
care I mean I am introducing a health
care reform bill to provide access to
health care for America's children and
I'm going to put on the table real new
money from the tobacco tax now that
fosters the debate and I really don't
think that this business of buying
Congress I think that's a newspaper
business I don't think members our
bought members represent their
constituents and I honestly don't know a
member Bernie except well there's a few
but the majority serve their
constituents I know that Nancy but I
think there is a reason as I'm sure you
will agree why when people in both
parties I'm not here just to criticize
the Republican Party clearly it's the
Democratic Party as well one of the
reasons why I proud to be an independent
but I think that there is a problem when
we go to front when people go to
fundraisers for $50,000 a play and the
President or mr. Gingrich holds
fundraisers why do people contribute
hundreds of thousands of dollars the
republican party of the democratic way
because they're interested in civics i
don't think so and the end result I
think Nancy what I'm not disagreeing
with you I'm not here to say a whole
members of Congress around the taker or
that's nonsense
but on the other hand there is a reason
why fewer and fewer people vote while
many working people no longer think
government represents their interest
while we have a trade policy which works
for corporate America why it took us so
long even raise the minimum wage I have
why we have a tax policy the faithless
the rich while we are the only major
industrialized country on Earth that
doesn't have a national health care
system there are reasons for that well I
i don't think the reasons have to do
with campaign contributions i think the
reasons we don't have a national health
care system is because we're an
entrepreneurial market society we
believe in a limited role of government
but i think the important thing is that
the way we run campaigns and the fact
that they that we've allowed them to
cost so much money discourages good
people from running I think that's
really the heart of why we need campaign
finance reform let's get our viewing
public involved in the conversation
Portland Oregon good morning good
morning I had two questions I was
wondering how many individual income tax
returns were filed two sure do they have
any idea Johnson's you have any numbers
should know those numbers but i don't
remember those numbers but i will say
that the great majority of taxpayers
filed voluntarily pay voluntarily and
pay the amount they should pay and we
have a better record in that regard than
most of the rest of the world and as a
figure that I heard was that the IRS's
are a hundred and around 110 million
individual income tax returns and I was
wondering if you're aware of how many
people no longer felt I know I'm not
accept that the number that don't file
has been increased by the actions of
Congress in the last tax round of tax
reform we did increase the threshold
below which you didn't need to pay
because you know for very good reason so
there are a lot of people that are not
obliged to pay taxes with the Earned
Income Tax Credit a lot of people are
filing tax reforms tax returns who don't
owe taxes but to whom the government
owes taxes because we are trying to
address exactly what Bernie pointed out
earlier that the payroll tax is very
aggressive and so we're trying to
actually return some of that payroll tax
to our lowest earners
order to expand their wages fort hood
texas good morning good morning I do
what I'm not sure I even qualified to
talk about taxis other than other than
just paying the taxes I pay but I was
interested in this is one of the first
time the clean David Harrell has had
anything this big on the front page and
it's the top right using about a third
of the Clintons targeted by mcdougal and
another thing before we get into that I
saw just a blip I'll free I don't even
remember who it was talking about it but
I haven't heard anything else about it
is there anything to the Arkansas
Attorney General being arrested for drug
dealing now are you reading today's
paper or yesterday's paper today's paper
this is a wednesday morning paper and
they have the mcdougal story see ya okay
that's i guess i guess you took it's a
little while you're too heavy to get the
four types of that with you know with
our new communications i'm i'm looking
here yeah this is when i picked up in
the yard this morning okay so you got
clean they they're all right sir thanks
for your questions can you add anymore
to that john and salt no word we did get
a question about fundraising and i'm
going to ask if you might comment on
this from miami lakes florida this
viewer writes why are we so exercised
about possible chinese government money
in our campaign for president have we
not through clandestine channels
funneled money to help elect individuals
or to assist political parties in other
nations and have done this for years
maybe we should clean up our own act
first comment well I think we should
clean up our own act first and I think
we should also make sure that people in
other countries are not influencing
elections in this country other caller
is right obviously for many years it is
no great secret that the CIA and other
government agencies have used money both
in terms of
of distorting elections in foreign
countries as well as the political
process in foreign countries and that's
wrong we have interfered time and time
again when we did not like movements or
political parties that set up for poor
people working people that's no secret
but just because we did and I hope we
put it into it we shouldn't be doing
that on the other hand it is a scary
situation and not a good situation to
believe if it is true that the foreign
governments are influencing our own
elections I think we have put an end to
that at least it's my belief that we put
an end to that kind of intervention and
that we did so a number of years ago
what we have been doing in recent years
is in far more honorable and very
important we have been putting
significant american dollars voluntarily
given but also some government dollars
into helping formerly communist nations
develop democratic systems of election
and we have given them a lot of support
in setting up political parties in
developing media approaches and
developing platforms and developing the
mechanism you know the government
mechanism to run elections we really
have done a good job I think of helping
companies learn how to do democracy how
them how to input in place the mechanics
of a democratic crash my concern Nancy
is the very often the types of parties
that we end up helping other parties
that represent wealthy people in poor
countries or not the poor people in
those countries well I think we
certainly do emphasize Cup supporting
parties that believe in both democracy
and a market economy Bernie because
market economies have produced
prosperity and non-market economies have
met some have some happen kettering ohio
good morning morning mrs. Johnson I
don't mean to be hopping on you he said
that you didn't know anyone who and the
representatives that took campaign money
that didn't act against the public as a
whole for the public as a whole sir
let's take the mortgage pcap people on
their mortgages on their houses there
was a bill that went into committee the
past diving was around 36 21 then so you
think that bill will ever get on the
floor no two people from North Carolina
put
stop to it because the companies are in
North Carolina I thought the people when
we elect them was supposed to be voting
for the country as a whole not one not
little minority and of the countries
another thing is yesterday everyone was
talking about taxes I don't think there
was one Republican who voted for the
income tax hike that the president put
in when he first got there but yet look
at what the country has done since then
the everything has gone down as far as
his oh what do you call it the amount of
deficit sir thanks i'm actually going to
spend a second on your first your first
question because the exact example you
gave which was that representatives from
north carolina stopped it because they
were in there there was the companies
were in their state it's worth just a
little bit of a discussion about the
role of the House of Representatives and
whether or not they are there to
represent the interests of the nation as
a whole as you suggested or the people
in their state mr. Sam's I think we're
there to do both I obviously look out
for the interest of the people the state
of Vermont I'm the only congressman from
one house and I'm sure Nancy sees that
it's our obligation to represent the
people of Connecticut that is our
obligation but I think also clearly for
the country to function we have to worry
about the 50 states and the entire
people in addition to now for the people
of Vermont I also try to emphasize a my
outlook the needs of working people in
this country because I think that as I
indicated earlier corporate America and
big money interests have a whole lot of
friends in Congress but working people
low-income people senior citizens
children we have the highest rate of
childhood poverty in the industrialized
world somehow those voices and those
needs do not get represented very
strongly and I try to look out for those
people as well I think members do look
out closely for the interests of the
people that they represent and most of
us do represent for the most part
working people children l
these citizens and of course a business
community and we all try to make sure
that there's a strong economy that their
jobs for our people that we tend to the
environmental needs of our district but
you can't just looked at your district
you know if if they pollute the waters
of the rivers north of Connecticut
Connecticut suffers so we work together
not only regionally but nationally and
we it is hard sometimes to explain the
national interest to people you
represent and I think NAFTA is a very
good example we have to mow open markets
we're not a very big market anymore
relative to our population and our
productive capability so we have to open
markets and yes that does mean that some
of our businesses will be more
competitive than other businesses so
there are ways in which members function
both and making national policy looking
at the financial interests and also
locally but I don't think generally why
would I want to add one other thing we
also work regionally and often the
regional issues are as important as any
single issue very totally bipartisan the
New England region right now is working
very hard to prevent an initiative that
would take a lot of road repair money
away from New England we have an
enormously difficult Road road
maintenance task our roads are older we
have very severe weather we support a
lot of interstate transportation because
we're small states and it's not us who
use our roads as much as interstate
users and so we have traditionally
gotten more Road money than the west
part of the country and now they want to
change the forms over here to our
disadvantage and we we work on those
issues in a bipartisan regional fashion
and that reflects the national dialogue
that goes on in Washington if you'll
both get another story ready next
waterbury connecticut good morning good
morning I have a question for mr.
Sanders okay my first question is is ben
& jerry's of corporation yeah it is so
therefore maybe we should raise our
corporate tax and Ben & Jerry's to
ungodly height maybe seventy-five
percent and that way you know when they
raised the prices of their ice cream
people won't buy it they won't employ
all those from
and you know they'll cease to exist see
your argument of taxing corporations I
mean that the tax is passed on to the
middle class no matter how you look at
it so you know it's a you think people
out here stupid I mean with you raised
the corporate tax that tax is passed on
to the people who work at corporations
who are the middle class people so
therefore I mean you know let's txt Ben
& Jerry's into oblivion thank you well
the gentleman obviously raises a good
question a lot of ramifications to it no
I did not say that we should raise
corporate taxes to seventy-five percent
what I did say is that in nineteen fifty
three corporations contributed about
thirty five percent of the tax dollars
that came into the federal government
today they are contributing less than
ten percent and what has happened since
that period is there has been a massive
shift from corporate America and buy in
lodge by and large corporate America is
owned by the wealthiest people in this
country they are the people who own most
not all but most of the stocks in most
of the buns in this country and what has
happened especially over the last twenty
years is the shift in the tax burden has
gone from the wealthy people their tax
rates have gone down and it has gone
increased on the middle class of working
people through an increase significant
increase in the payroll taxes also as
the federal government has cut back on
federal aid the cities and towns and
education local taxes such as the
property tax in the state of Vermont
many other states in this country have
gone up and they are also very
regressive taxes so essentially over the
last 20 years the tax system in this
country has become more and more
regressive meanwhile in terms of the
economy what has happened is the
wealthiest people have become much
richer we now have the dubious
distinction of having the most unfair
distribution of income and wealth in the
industrialized world the richest 1% of
the population alan's over forty percent
of the wealth of America more than the
bottom ninety percent the middle class
is declining people are working longer
hours for lower wages and twenty-two
percent of our kids live in poverty so I
would argue that policies which cut
taxes for the rich and large
corporations pass them on for the middle
class and result in significant cutbacks
in revenue coming into the federal
coffins meaning less money for education
less money for our cities and towns is
public policy well I would certainly say
that the tax structure the tax burden on
middle-class families is heavier now
than it has ever been we had testimony
before Ways and Means Committee just
yesterday that if the child exemption
that people got in 1942 had kept pace
with inflation families would get a
ten-thousand-dollar exemption per child
now and they get a 2500 per child so we
have not kept we have not kept in mind
as we've moved forward the burdens of
young families and we need to reform
that and that's one of the reasons
frankly by the Republicans have driven
so hard on this issue a family tax
relief the president also ran on it we
need to do something about middle class
tax relief this session but I i think
the caller's point is a very important
one and I think and Bernie's answer he
must a very important point and that is
that as a result of government policy
making it easier to have an IRA IRA
encouraging pension plans that were I
array type vehicles 401k type vehicles
we have seen an explosion in America of
middle-class investment in stocks in the
economy and corporations and so if you
look the mutual fund role in our economy
those are all ordinary people owning a
piece of the action and I think that's
healthy I've been a big advocate of
Aesop's which is employer stock owners
owner ownership structures to companies
and I think what's happening in America
in terms of stock ownership and
investment is really a good thing well I
would just say Nancy there's truth to
what you're saying but let's not get
ourselves the richest 1% of the
population on forty percent of the
wealth of America they also pay most of
the taxes well again you're excluding
the payroll tax on I think that that's
what they're there can't ignore it and
income taxes they pay by far the
majority of it but they earn significant
significantly more than paper paper yeah
but if you add the federal taxes and the
payroll taxes and state taxes and local
taxes by and large the tax system today
is significantly more aggressive than it
was 20 years ago and the burden and I
don't disappear he was falling very
heavily on them
class the concerns that I have with
Republican proposals it's very easy to
give tax breaks to the middle class I
strongly support that but then if the
end result is we're going to cut back on
Social Security if we're going to cut
back on Medicare and Medicaid you're
taking from one hand and punishing
somebody else AB stop no Republican has
ever ever proposed taking from Social
Security birdie and you know it yeah
let's talk about the CPI of the consumer
prices whole lot of president is talking
president whether or not the Consumer
Price Index is accurately developed
scientifically to adjust for inflation
and if they find that it isn't accurate
then the technical people will propose
some adjustment or you know that that is
nothing to do with from socials
everything to do with aching for Social
Security I don't think it is just an
accident that this issue is developing
right now is one thing to talk out the
opposing opposed lowering the UCP I
oppose opposed changing the CPI until
the technical work is thoroughly
completed it won't and I said I would
hope that you will join me in taking a
look at the CPI as it applies the senior
citizens because Nancy in Vermont and I
suspect in kinetic in fact for senior
citizens there increase in inflation is
probably higher than the general public
in Vermont senior citizens can't afford
the escalating costs the prescription
drugs home heating coil is a sword and I
think if you take a look at the CPI for
seniors we will raise the cost of living
increases the seniors not cut them let
me get a call in Warren Michigan good
morning good morning how are you fine
sir what's on your mind a couple quick
points and I'll get out of the way first
of all it's a seems to me Ludacris to
talk about campaign reform when Congress
is unwilling to enforce the perfect
flaws I mean what are we doing fat cat
cafe in reform then come back two three
four years for now because somebody
abused didn't say well let's have
campaign reform again the second item is
a I don't know that finances the problem
the problem to me is truth in
advertising such as the Democrats a vile
attack unsupported Medicare cuts which
were non-existent I mean I to me that
was the most despicable thing in the
world if there was truth in advertising
or truth in campaigns
in campaigns maybe maybe the people
would listen more I turned off early in
the last election because I got tired of
hearing about Gingrich Cotts Gingrich
cut so dull eccentric arts you know
that's all I had thank you kindly thank
you very much miss Johnson I think it is
unfortunate that the discussion about
Medicare got off track in the last
election you know President Clinton said
we needed to slow the rate of growth and
Medicare from ten percent to seven
percent Hillary Clinton testified before
the Ways and Means Committee saying we
need to slow it to six percent at that
point that that's what she thought there
is broad agreement that we must slow the
rate of growth and Medicare to seven
percent met it because Medicare is
actually going bankrupt it last year
paid out more than payments then it took
in this year it will do the same
everyone agrees the trustees of the
program where members of the president's
cabinet have actually laid out very
clearly for the Congress that the
program will have no funds left in three
more years I consider this a crisis I
think the Congress ought to act and
furthermore we as a member of the
subcommittee responsible for this we can
see how we can slow the rate of growth
in Medicare spending and actually
provide better benefits for our senior
citizens because Medicare is a terribly
outdated benefit program so there are
ways that we could help the seniors by
talking honestly about how we meet the
crisis in Medicare and claiming that we
were cutting Medicare when we were
actually going to increase expenditures
per senior more in the next seven years
and then the Prix de seen seven years
was the kind of dishonest politics that
is doing exactly what that caller caller
said it's turning people off that's why
people aren't voting they are just
turned off by the way we run campaigns
we don't talk honestly during campaigns
about the problems and that is a
terrible terrible problem for a
democracy well let me just pick up on
that point if my memory is correct and
you correctly from wrong Nancy as a
result of the Republican Gingrich
proposal Medicare premiums would have
gone up by five hundred dollars at the
end of seven
is five hundred dollars yeah I believe
and I think that it is for example I
mean but Nancy is saying what's looks
let's analyze with Nancy saying if
hypothetically inflation in a given year
is six percent any work that gets a
three percent increase in his or her
wages and the boss says hey I'm giving
you more money you gotta wage this is
not a cut well for the workers point of
view his rent is going up maybe as taxes
are going up it is a cut now I am not
arguing with you there is no debate yeah
the benefits went up but compared to the
needs and inflation it was a cut and
we're talking about semantics if at the
end of seven years a senior citizen in
Connecticut or Vermont who's trying to
survive an eight thousand dollar Xia has
to pay five hundred dollars a year more
for Medicare and invest and I'm not
arguing with you that we can improve the
Medicare system make it more efficient
but if you're paying five hundred
dollars more for arguably what might be
the same type of services I consider
that a cut let me also say that right
now even if you left Medicare alone
Medicare does not cover as you know
prescription drugs as you know you know
that you know that medicare has
deductibles and co-payments it is not a
strong system we should ask ourselves
why throughout the rest of the
industrialized world in every single
country there are national health care
system which guarantee virtually all
health care to their people well we have
a system which is not strong enough
today the Republican proposal would have
raised premiums and to the best of my
understanding cut back on the quality of
service Bernie this is exactly the kind
of dialogue that I think doesn't help
premiums have gone up in Medicare every
single year because Part B premiums
cover a percent of the cost of the
program and as the Part B program costs
go up the premium goes up a few dollars
every year us cat any senior citizen and
that's the way it's been let me just
finish this the the the the fact is that
the premiums were not going to go up any
more under the reform proposal than they
had gone up in the past it would have
been exactly the same now the important
issue is that over and above that
premium increase the cost of Medicare
was going to go up far
more rapidly we were going to fund it
from payroll taxes which we've done
traditionally but also from general fund
revenues and the amount the taxpayers
we're going to put into Medicare is
going to go up every single year far in
excess of premiums but not only is it
wrong to say premiums were going to go
up in a way they hadn't in the past
they're going to go up in the same way
they had in the past but also we know we
can deliver better care to seniors more
care to seniors for the same money and
managed care plans out there in Medicare
are offering prescription drugs they're
covering the co-payments and deductibles
they're providing some preventive health
care and we have an obligation to at
least give seniors the choice of those
plans we can argue to my mind again to
tell seniors who are trying to survive
on seven or eight thousand dollars a
year that they can have to pay five
hundred dollars more is an outrage and
unacceptable second of all what we have
to ask ourselves why it is that in this
country we have 40 million Americans who
are zero health insurance you have more
than that who are underinsured we have
per capita the most expensive
inefficient health care system in the
entire world and that has to do with the
fact that you have insurance companies
rippin off the people a few years ago
you remember us health care of major HMO
was sold to aetna at the end of the gate
the guy ended up 1 billion dollars
wealthier and I am not so convinced that
managed care is working quite as
smoothly as you suggested as I'm hearing
many complaints throughout those waiting
for a long time what a quick response we
just it just to get back to the car's
original issue the debate about Medicare
is not about cutting Medicare the debate
about Medicare is providing better
benefits for seniors at an affordable
price for seniors and for the rest of
the population and we have to act to
save Medicare and in order to save
Medicare and keep it I mean it's the one
of the most important programs for our
seniors and for their children to say
that we have to have a far more honest
dialogue in the future that we've been
able you know some people are in suspect
some of your leaders like tegami don't
believe in Medicare but no I don't I
don't I don't agree with you and that he
absolutely does both of you get your
pens ready because i'm gonna take two
calls in a row to catch up with some of
these folks have been waiting for a
while if you take some notes and we'll
come back to their questions first is
sparta new jersey oh good morning good
morning
I know I heard representative nancy
Johnson indicate that special interests
don't affect people's boats by almond
part of the electorate I'll consider
myself special interest even though i
can't give barred sums of money we had
our congress and senate sit with their
feet up on the bench while the banks and
savings and loans glued it to place we
got the bill if i earn a hundred dollars
in interest I put it on my income and
pay tax on it but if I pay out interest
on a credit card or an auto installment
loan I can't deduct it now that's not
special interest I guess I'd like to
know if we are the one of you know your
I heard nancy Johnson I only heard the
tail end about IRAs what percent of the
population were able to economically
contribute and open up an IRA I was like
to type be very surprised if you knew
the answer to that okay thank you for
your call i'm going to move on to newton
massachusetts and we'll come back to the
table newton go ahead please yes i had
several questions for representative
saunders i'd like to know why my husband
who although we earns a significant
income and self-employed and works 80
hours a week self-employed so he pays
both halves of the Social Security tax
both halves of the Medicaid attacks why
is or Medicare tax why is he not
considered a working person second of
all if you tax a hundred percent of
everything that an individual earns over
two hundred thousand dollars you'd pay
for the government for 35 days where are
you going to get the rest of the revenue
to pay for the government second thirdly
if the government has so many programs
to take care of people that's why people
in your state and other states are
perhaps living on five hundred dollars a
month social security because they have
been discouraged from saving because the
government will provide they will
provide social security medicare and all
the other floor programs please ask why
effort also is not rewarded the effort
is saving the effort of planning for
one's own future thanks very much
alright how about if we take them in
reverse order
ticket to suggest that people are being
discouraged from working flies in the
face of reality because of the collapse
of the middle class and the fact that
real wages have not kept pace with
inflation and we have a growing gap
between the rich and the poor the middle
classes in fact working longer hours
than has ever worked before in fact what
is really frightening now is that you
have people the average worker in
America and i was working about a
hundred and sixty hours a year more than
was the case 15 years ago people are
working their butts off but the fact is
that wages are going down you're having
women would rather stay home with the
kids being forced to work people working
long long hours problems wages are have
dropped precipitable precipitously in
this country the woman talked before
what constitutes a working person I'm
not suggesting for a moment that wealthy
people or CEOs do not work very very
hard course many of them do but what we
have to ask ourselves is whether it is
equitable whether it is right that the
CEOs of the largest corporations in
America now earn a hundred and seventy
times what their work is make and that
we have the greatest gap between the
rich between CEOs and workers of any
country in the world that's wrong sure
CEOs are working hard but so ordinary
middle-class and working-class families
they need a break as well now why all
wage is going on why do people have to
work so hard there are a lot of reasons
minimum wage has not kept pace with
inflation our trade policy is a disaster
has cost us a major trade deficit we
have lost millions of decent
manufacturing jobs and so forth but
believe me the working-class and
middle-class are working very hard woman
talks about self-employed people having
to pay 7.5 + 7.5 she's right I think
that's wrong that is hurting a whole lot
of middle-class families in terms of
social security taxes our sparty New
Jersey caller used the savings and loan
as an example of how special interests
do get paid attention to in Washington
well I I would remind him that the
collapse in the savings alone industry
was not among federally chartered banks
it was among state-chartered banks and
so the federal government had to get
into state action change state law
changed the federal role and try to bail
the system out but he owes the first
caller said special interests don't
affect that I was saying special
interest don't affect people's votes
what affect people's votes are the
interests of their constituents and of
course in Connecticut I had a lot of
consider
Jones deeply affected by the collapse of
the bank's Connecticut was one of the
hardest hit States so I spent a lot of
time on banking issues and trying to
restore to the small person the right to
gain a small loan so I think that I the
his fundamental point that a special
interest I somehow influenced members
votes more than their constituents is
just simply not a point I agree with
them on I think that members react
primarily to the interests of their
constituents I've got a fax here I'd
like to show you from a viewer in
Hastings Michigan who sent us an article
from the hometown paper the battle creek
enquirer with this little item it says
poll most give IRS positive rating this
is a reaction to your comments earlier
at this is date lined Annapolis and it
says to hear the politicians in
Washington speak one would expect to see
the masses preparing for a full-scale
rebellion is Tuesday's tax deadline
approaches they go on to say that an
associated press poll last week for out
sentiments showing that seven in 10
adults give the agency a positive rating
on its ability to promptly inaccurately
handle taxpayers returns and inquiries
this viewer writes along with that
article miss Johnson instead of tearing
this great nation down why not fix the
problems Republicans think that
everything is wrong I wonder how we have
even survived these last hundred years
please note what this article says you
try to make out like all Americans are
unhappy with this government let's hit a
happy medium a concerned citizen well I
hope that he listened carefully to my
remarks at the beginning because I was
careful to point out that the IRS has
really made some remarkable progress in
the last few years and that they do some
very good work their electronic filing
system is coming along very well they
are answering more of the taxpayers
calls but we are having some problems
and they in the hearing that we're going
to convene this morning they did a very
good job of implementing this new
electronic filing system for a lot of
businesses but when they sent out the
directions to the smallest businesses
now these are people like the husband of
the preceding caller he doesn't have any
tax staff he has to read this himself
figure out what he's to do and do it and
when the IRS sends out a letter that
doesn't clearly line out your
alternatives in the new situation but
your obligations are what you're
costs are going to be in a situation
that frankly was pretty simple fence
they do a disservice to the ordinary
taxpayer out there and what we're trying
to do is make the IRS far more taxpayer
sensitive we had a hearing recently
where we ask their the advocates who
deal directly with the public to come
and tell the Congress what are the major
problems that the taxpaying public has
so we can address them and instead of
that we got something from Washington an
old list of the problems from 1993 now
luckily we had a panel after that of
advocates and the advocates actually
tilt told us some very interesting
information and we're just trying to
help the IRS be more customer sensitive
now Bernie mentioned that in his part of
the country they've been merging offices
and they've had some problems with that
in my part of the country they merged
some offices and it has gone very very
well and the Hartford office has done a
really spectacular job of managing this
change in a way that they've really met
the customers interest but I'm glad this
caller called because the IRS is doing
some very good work they are there to
serve they have some excellent customer
assistance people we just have to but
there when an agency spends four billion
dollars to try to upgrade their
technology and comes out with as few
accomplishments is this agency their
problems not necessarily with just the
people but with the system I would agree
with much of what Nancy said but what I
don't agree with is is the role of big
money and influencing Congress and I
think that's we've got to be pretty
naive not to believe that people are
contributing hundreds of thousands of
dollars to the parties of their choice
and the politicians are not influencing
public policy and I would give you one
example we talked about special interest
and we talked a lot about welfare which
most people assumed to mean programs to
go to poor people but in fact corporate
welfare and that is tax breaks and
subsidies go to large multinational
corporations pens of amounting to
significantly more than the program's
the go to poor people and that would be
a direct it seems to me a direct result
of the influence of big money second of
all the cold war is over and I don't
know why we continue to spend the kinds
of money we spend on the military and
why we don't see the peace dividend that
we were
stay after the Cold War ended we want a
strong military I want a strong military
but you don't have to build b-2 bombers
for a billion and a half dollars a plane
we don't have to spend a hundred billion
dollars a year defending Europe and Asia
against the non-existent enemy it seems
to me that if we're serious about
balancing the budget there are ways to
cut back on corporate welfare military
spending doing away with the tax breaks
that we've given to the rich you can
balance the budget that way without
having to cut back on the CPI and lower
social security you don't have to cut
back on Medicare or Medicaid and throw a
million children into poverty by
so-called welfare reform so I think we
can move toward a balanced budget we
should do it in a fair way and I think
special interests are influencing
Congress in a way that's unfortunate
about ten minutes left with our two
guests next Tampa Florida good morning
how do you do this morning just fine sir
oh great I just want to say I'm just uh
I get so tired of hearing the same old
liberal mindset stuff that comes out of
this guy Mr Sanders he keeps saying the
same old things that the working class
people everybody's working class there's
no classes in this country like there's
this class in that class everybody's
working class you have a job I have a
job we're all working class the business
owners have a job they work it's the
same old thing but you got to understand
mrs. Johnson is the guy sitting across
from you does not care about shrinking
government does not care about the
lowering of taxes does not care about
getting out of the way so that this
country can become an economic
powerhouse it's the same old stuff we
need more weapons to have higher taxes
for the the programs that they want and
I see that yesterday he must have been
that loan i vote against the two-thirds
majority to raise taxes because it's the
same thing if you put a cap on the taxes
then you have to focus on the spending
thank you right well let me just I mean
I'm glad that he asked that question he
said I believe I'm quoting correctly
there are no classes in this country end
of code if you believe that I've got a
couple of bridges that I can sell you I
mean that is preposterous we have the
most unequal distribution of wealth and
incoming the entire industrialized world
the richest 1% of the population owns
more wealth than ninety percent it's an
article that I wanted to get to in the
wall street journal journal about Rupert
Murdoch expanding his heart you know
owns the television networks do you
understand the understand what wealth
and power is about if you think we live
in a classless it's like who do you
think makes the decisions regarding
whether our jobs stay in America or go
to China where they're paying people
twenty cents an hour we'll go to Mexico
where they're paying people fifty cents
an hour who do you think owns NBC is
owned by General Electric who do you
think contributes hundreds of thousands
of dollars to the politic to the
political parties of their choice the
United States in fact is a very class
structured society the rich are getting
richer the middle class is shrinking
people are working longer hours for low
wages people have given up on the
political process because they know the
big money influences both political
products such suggest there are no
classes in America is a silly remark I
absolutely disagree with Bernie a
hundred percent all the data
demonstrates if you look at the tax data
who's in what bracket the percent of the
population in different bracket stays
about even but the people who are there
change all the time we are the most
mobile society in the entire world and
furthermore you've said over and over
again during this paper during this
program out wages going down if you
would look at wages as the total
compensation package that is benefits
and cash compensation wages have gone up
we are an entrepreneurial society we are
growing society and frankly we are also
a society in which the tax burden is at
an all-time high and in Congress we need
to take far more seriously the fact that
there are many programs we fund that no
longer really are very effective welfare
reform was a perfect example any society
that is in the habit of paying people
not to work has very serious problems
and welfare reform was about paying
people to get them into the workforce
paying people for work even if it's
part-time work while they get the skills
to become in fully independent now I'd
be the last to say that the welfare
reform bill was perfect but it certainly
is going to create a sea change in our
society at all
ready has as it focuses people on
creating their own future and creating a
future of independent and action now
that doesn't relieve us of the
responsibility to take care of those who
can't support themselves for for reasons
of disability and we certainly need to
do that but I see this is a time when we
need to focus on tax relief for the
working families of our country and with
that tax relief has to go cuts in
spending we have had an enormous civil
authority over you to say we haven't had
a peace dividend is outrageous we have
shrunk down the army the Navy the Air
262 bill looks open up let me finish my
suggestion to suggest as you have
suggested that wages are going up let
the people know spectrum sensation total
compensation more in more workers are
losing health benefits in their jobs not
because employers are cutting back and
asking the pay higher deductibles and
co-payments the fact of the matter is
and it's incredible to me that you would
disagree with us the middle class is
shrinking people are working longer
hours for low wages women now have got
to work alongside of the husbands
because one person can no longer bring
in enough income I would sleep the most
economists and most members of Congress
would agree with that and understand
that a gap between attorneys no question
about that they're working harder and
furthermore there barring a lot more
anguish about jobs security than they
ever have like because many of our time
ago so among any more opportunity than
they have any other nation absolutely
and we could let's talk about what's
going on in America and what's going on
in America is we are seeing in
Connecticut in Vermont a significant
decline in our manufacturing and I
manufacture of manufacturing in this
country now one of the things that is
going on is that when both Republicans
and Democrats bush and Clinton talk
about the creation of new jobs you know
what they're forgetting they're
forgetting to talk about what these jobs
pay yes we are creating millions of new
jobs many of these jobs are paying
people six bucks an hour seven bucks an
hour they don't have benefits and these
are jobs in communities where people
used to have decent angel let's take
manufacturing New England has been big
in manufacturing and remains big and
manufacturing we as a nation have
traditionally produced twenty percent of
our gross gross national product for
manufacturing we are now producing
twenty-two percent for men
facturing and we are the leaders that is
we provide the highest quality lowest
cost goods in 20 and 19 of the 21
technologies and I will take you through
a tour go with me to any local
department store in Connecticut one
second Connecticut Vermont or Washington
DC and you know you're going to see the
products being manufactured not in the
United States of America the clothing
that we wear the television sets that we
buy the VCRs the sneakers china china
mexico and so forth and so on we have
160 billion dollar trade deficit which
correlates the loss of millions of
decent-paying jobs see you and I look at
the economy in a different way yeah I
acknowledge the people on top have never
had it so good in my view the working
class the middle class is hurting
people's wages have gone down that
working long hours yeah losing but you
are just ignoring the fact that we are
producing manufactured goods and selling
them all what do we have at rexall
hundred and sixty billion dollars
because we also purchase an enormous
amount of goods from all over the world
and that has helped to bring prosperity
to other nations and create a more
prosperous and peaceful world community
and international trade in my estimation
is as important to peace and prosperity
in the future as any see I agree with
international trade no argument but if
you think the current trade policy of
NAFTA and got is working well if you're
not concerned about 160 billion record
that's a record-breaking trade deficit
than we have a strong disagree remember
NAFTA gave a preference to American
manufacturing Goods people forget that
in NAFTA sixty-two percent of the
industrial product components have to be
made within the community that is Canada
United States and Mexico that is a
preference we have a lot of policies
that encourage American manufacturing
and support American facturing
manufacturing and I've been a big
proponent of protecting America's
industrial base we have to do that at
the same time we have a trait we we have
international trade policies that foster
trade and prosperity seems slightly very
clear just now you probably right and
dancing basis village really and we have
a record-breaking you agree a
record-breaking trade deficit if we have
a record-breaking trade deficit that how
can anyone suggest that our trade
policies are because if you look at
capital flows and a lot of complicated
things it's not as good as simple
pictures as you paint further
or remember jobs associated with export
exports are high your pain that's right
and one of the reasons we want to create
the 16th international market is to
assure that our standard of living Rises
unfortunately it's not working current
policy I wanted to there was a very
interesting debate so I wanted to let
you go on for a bit unfortunately they
have about five minutes left and two
callers on the line so feel burwood it
and we're gonna do once again take two
calls in her own that'll be our last
Struthers Ohio good morning good morning
what do you got for us sir oh I have a
question for both both of the
representatives I'm a semi retired CPA
been dealing with the tax laws since
nineteen forty nine and we could go on
for a week as to what's happened but
anyway recently a client of mine that
one of the few lifestyle service got a
letter from the IRS and he happens to be
fairly largest only the letter stated
that because of a gap ruling that his
company because they have more than
fifty thousand dollars a year in payroll
tax payments to the banks had to gwen's
absolutely had to go into a new system
my question is how can get dictate to an
American company what they must do and
where they ant and wears a special
interest there can only be one place and
that's the banks okay sir thanks not
much time left let's take a call from
Pueblo and we'll come back to our guests
Pablo Colorado yes I am calling
regarding the health care problems that
we're having and about a year ago I call
the Federal Elections Commission and I
asked him to send me a readout on some
contributions made by the Golden Rule
insurance company and a considerable
amount of money was sent to go back and
also considerable amount of money was
sent to representative Johnson or her
campaigns at that time representative
Johnson I believe
was chairman of the House Ethics
Committee I investigating go pack and
yet I believe she received money from go
back she also received money from Golden
Rule Financial Corporation and golden
move health insurance and these are
examples of how people are put off and
this is why we don't have why we do not
have a reform for campaigns and that's
why we don't have health insurance hey
thanks reasonable we will take those
again in reverse order would you take
that I absolutely reject your the
implication of your comment that I could
be bought by a contribution from an
insurance company first of all I get
contributions from insurance companies I
get contributions from consumer groups I
get contributions from people on both
sides of many issues because I listen to
people about their issues and I try to
work through issues in a way that comes
to a solution that meets the interests
of the people I represent that is the
public interest now hartford connecticut
is home to many insurance companies
insurance companies in connecticut our
major employer yes i understand the
industry yes i want to be sure that
government policy allows the insurance
industry to be strong and healthy
because it is a critical industry
providing a lot of security to both
individuals and businesses throughout
America and we would not want the
insurance industry to collapse but does
that mean that I don't introduce
legislation that helps people even when
insurance companies are unhappy
absolutely i introduced the first bill
to require health insurance plans to
take you without discriminating against
you for pre-existing conditions the
insurance companies weren't happy about
that but i knew from my constituents
that they had to have what we call
portability that they couldn't we
couldn't leave them in the position of
changing health insurance plans and
being discriminated against for
pre-existing conditions and I introduced
that first bill even though I represent
a state with big insurance interest
interests and some of those companies
vehemently oppose my legislation so you
know don't reduce life to such
simplistic terms sir we represent our
constituents we
the problems in their lives and we
propose solutions and sometimes those
solutions tick off some of our allies
and sometimes they don't but our job is
to serve the people's interest and
frankly I I'd be happy to I wish I had
more time to go into this because that
health insurance bill that I introduced
because it did alienate a lot of
traditional interestings industries in
Connecticut is a perfect example of how
representative serve the interests of
their people the needs of the people
they represent let me briefly deal with
the other issue the issue of gas I'm not
familiar with the provision that they
generally refer to but what one of the
aspects of gap and our trade agreements
that does concern me is for example in
this country we have pushed for
environmental regulations regarding the
kinds of pesticides that may be used so
that we don't consume DDT and our food
and so forth what does concern me is
that other countries that do not have
these standards are able now to import
their products into this country putting
our own growers at a disadvantage and
that's one of the aspects of
international trade we have the right
local communities have the right at it
seems to me to make legislation which
works well for their communities this
country has the right to make laws that
work well for our own people and in the
under the guise of so-called free trade
and the World Trade Organization many of
the standards that we believe are
important are going to be ruled in
violation of free trade and that
concerns me back just a moment to the
electronic filing problem and the first
caller saying that he got this letter on
behalf of the business he should live it
tuned in to the hearing that we're going
to have this morning on exactly that
issue on exactly that letter and what
that small business really is obliged to
do and how they can do it and how we
believe it will be in their interest and
and and so and so forth so okay he
should tune in last question and a quick
one that last caller did bring up the
ethics committee process which of course
our viewers know you were chair
associate press is running a story this
morning Gingrich narrows options for
paying ethics penalties it says sources
close to mr. Gingrich all speaking on
the condition of anonymity said that the
speaker had narrowed his choices to to
paying most of the penalty himself or
establishing a legal defense fund to
raise the entire $300,000 as either
former chairman of the chairman of this
process or a member of the Republican
caucus do you have an opinion
as I have said repeatedly in the past I
believe he should pay the amount
personally but I am proud of the fact
that the Ethics Committee through a
majority vote or in the on the final
action a near majority vote concluded
work on all of the cases involving mr.
Gingrich and in the in this last round
provided the recommended the toughest
penalty against any sitting speaker it
was broadly supported by the house so I
think the Ethics Committee carried out
its responsibilities really very well in
a tough environment came to an honorable
conclusion did propose a very tough
penalty against a sitting speaker and
now I think he should truly pay out of
his own resources comment to nestle
close I think you should be out of his
own resources thanks to our two special
guests at the table congressman Bernie
Sanders of Vermont and nancy Johnson of
Connecticut hope you'll both come back
we'll be back in a couple minutes